saw roblox valet and i said uh hey i'm  boys with chad and jt and he goes they  are so good really oh that's nice  no that's thank you for sharing that  yeah yeah thank you he said he's so he  was very happy and then i was like  and then he's like cool  i already have a question ready for him  next time i see him on set i'm gonna ask  him what it was like to work with curtis  hansen in the late 80s because he's a  director i like and i don't think  anyone's throwing him in that queue yet  dude nice  [ __ ] yeah they did a movie called like  bad influence by james spader before  hanson went on his like murderous streak  of just like five bangers i was gonna  butter him up was saying i listened to  his podcast but i think he beat me no  that's good no let's hit him from both  front the michael douglas episode in  particular my dad asked and as he  finishes it he's like that's why you  podcast